hi I'm Sebastian I am Matteo and we're
gonna give a workshop on neural networks
applies to computer vision and how to
debug problems that happen in your
network training
yeah there will be sort of two major
parts here which are interacting so one
is reviewing sorts of and two and
pipelines for various computer vision
tasks on a toy application for
demonstration purposes and alongside we
are going to show me Sebastian is going
to show some training issues and how to
solve them so the tasks we are going to
present are actually so so this is the
data set we are going to work for this
toy toy application so this will be a
data set of images basically
representing integer editions okay and
out of these guys were going to do three
things
first thing is semantic segmentation so
Samantha's imitation is a general task
is a very hard task in general and it's
about to label each pixel of an image
according to what what is it showing so
this thing would be card this will be
road this will be street sign and so on
buildings so we are going to segment
this image into background which would
be which is represented as white pixel
in this mask the plus sign are going to
segment the digits the single digits
then we are going through also or is it
addition so we are going to actually
regress the result of the of the
operation and yeah that's it I'm also
character counting so we are going to
count the number of characters here so
this is what one over twenty example
looks like input two plus eighty nine
target sum in one count is four
characters and the mask battle ask so
first of all we have to generate the
synthetic data set and you just have to
run this block here data generation
without caring too much about it
so let's look at it they were generated
so let's BCD actual these actual things
required to do to generate the reset so
this is an example of two examples we
have input target sum and a mask so the
mask so these images are 18 by 40 images
so the mask could be a matrix of 18 by
40 and we can show using a replot some
nice validation of the mask so here's a
random sample of how many ten example of
the reset so let's start with the some
tasks so some task is this part and this
part of the data sets basically and we
are going to tackle these tasks using
these networks so I will now spend some
time commenting on how these network is
built so of course a very basic building
block for deep learning contribution
application you have a bunch of
completion layers and a bunch of
linearities so this ramp here is not is
equivalent so this guy which is the
usual relevant non-linearity maybe a
more familiar we have also this nice
shortcut here so what is usually I'm
sorry I'll still bigger okay sure okay
so what it's usually used alongside so
usually before some of these rap guys
it's very common to you this batch
normalization layer which basically
standardized mininum very mean and
variance of a mini batch during training
and makes make stuff converge faster and
converge more nicely we're going to use
it only once for for simplicity so what
else can we say about this let's look at
the representation size so in this task
we're going to input an image and output
the sum of the numbers so a vector
our input will be a 1 by 18 by 40 tensor
1 is the number of color channels
because this imager
these images are grayscale as it usually
happens in these kinds of tasks this
representation at least for this spatial
size is shrinked as the processing goes
on so you start with 18 by 40 you got 9
by 25 times 3 5 and the number channel
is very differently source let's talk
about the number of channels you may see
that we have these architectural
features a number of these three
convolutional layers with kernel size 3
by 3 so this 3 is the kernel size which
is equivalent to this thing which is
probably more clear so we have a number
of these guys which Oh should have
mentioned so these these dull samplings
are realized with strided convolutions
usually people use pooling layers too
but you are not using them here actually
we will but for a different purpose
later so about the chat about about the
channel so you may you will see we have
these 3 by 3 convolution layers here
which are sandwiched by one by one
convolutions every time so this thing is
a typical architectural trick which is
used in literature
it's actually an overkill for this toy
task but is just to show you how things
are done usually so this thing is called
bottle nets architecture and basically
we have to compare this with an
architectural which you don't have these
sandwiches it's only you only have the 3
by 3 convolution stacked one after
another and the size of the kernel is 3
by 3 every time it's called bottlenecks
yeah it's called bottlenecks because
you're basically shrinking so suppose
you remove all these so you have to
compare this with
during which all the convolutional 3x3
and all the channel 16 okay so it's
called butter leg beef because suppose
you have 16 channels incoming you
squeeze them into 8 channels using these
one by one guy yeah you squeeze them
into 8 channels and you do the 3 by 3
convolution which is the costly one
between two picture maps which have a
channel set of 16 and this says you
provided that you don't shrink too much
because otherwise you you know you
you're you're you're losing too much
information
this give you a lot of nice properties
which are basically with respect to the
plain 3x3 stock you have less parameters
so less prone to overfitting you have
more lonely arity because you can put
more nonlinearities here in between the
steps so the model gets more expressive
and since you have less parameters you
the thing is also faster yeah no it's
just you you like what happens in this
case usually is that you start one after
another until you reach the performance
you you Lego blocks these plain Lego
blocks nothing more than that
so after this type of convolution with
this like fancy batch norm alone here at
some point we flatten so we come to 16
channels 3 by 5 special size we flatten
all this into a 240 sized vector and
then we use a linear layer which is an
is a fully connected layer so it not
just doing a matrix multiplication using
a 240 by 1 matrix so actually ok and
this one thing is what we'll hope will
be the final sum okay so let's obstruct
our training set out of the bigger set
so this is the sum training set and I'll
show you you know oh okay it's it's the
other syntax so what is it all yeah
so input output input and outputs
okay and let's train so we have we have
designed this example to be quick so
this guy will train in less than a
minute we have twinning laws violation
laws okay well well other people will be
using a CPU so it's better to keep it to
keep the pace I will switch to CPU to
GPU at some point well the more
bottlenecks he puts the more powerful
the model is so like you will achieve in
the end the lower training error but be
sure you will do better better and train
this is usual machine learning
generalization problem the more
expressive your model is the more you
can feed your training set better but
you actually don't care about that you
care about the audition and the Schloss
and you basically you have to compare
that with the amount of data you have so
if you have a lot of data you can afford
to train powerful model because because
you it will still generalize well so it
since usually in real life what it's
fixed more or less fixes the amount of
data that's your budget basically and
you have to so that's what the power
that's what you can afford in terms of
how powerful your model is that sets the
scale okay so this is our final train
some nets so we're getting four sample
tests so these are disease these are the
images to be and let's see how well we
well it's quite it's not perfect but
it's quite reasonable and trust me if if
I run for four hundred rounds instead of
200 you you you would see better results
okay
okay disapprove yep
you're my microphone is not okay and
yeah see now I don't know what am i
someone help me
lower that's melody actually I can talk
loudly like I'm quite good at talking
loud so I okay let's do 500
using GPU power
let's see if we're doing better
well we are look we are much closer than
before yes I'd say that we are okay
let's move on to counting so now I get
action for counting so this is very
similar they are they're sharing
basically the same the same part which
really does then to the multitask thing
so this will be much quicker
this part is exactly the same part of
the summing Nets actually this part is
this exactly same of the summing that
except that here see we still at the
linear layer for the summing part but
with different dimensionality because
now we are going to show in deep
learning difficulties a classification
task so you either classify the image as
having three four or five characters
because we're only we're using up to two
digit numbers so you can have two
characters if the image is like 2 plus 3
2 Plus 3 and you can add as is 5 so we
have 3 classes so what changes here is
that so
we are not maybe this is much more
explicit our finally only we want to
output a length 3 vector which going
into the software clays layer is
basically normalized and it's turned
into the probabilities of the image
having three digits having sorry three
characters for cartas or five characters
and these is also stated but this guy
which is a decoder of type class with
classes 3 4 5 the reason why I could
also do this thing so not specifying the
final dimensionality is because these
guys present here so there is an
inference system which detects oh you
know I have three classes okay so like
the output of this network must be like
three vector and so I can infer this
thing to be a tree okay this is
automatically detected that way and you
can see it also here
okay so let's extract the relevant data
set for this particular task and start
training again
as you see generalization is actually
better in this case than in some case
because the by addition is tracking the
the training loss more closely the blue
is the validation yeah of course and
also there's a nice picture when you put
a rendition sets your final train nets
will not be the network at the end of
the training but it will be the network
which had the best validation loss
throughout so that's the way in which
you can prevent you it's basically
implementing early stopping
automatically it tracks the training
loss closely yes that's that's that
that's a common machine learning
phenomenology if you want so that means
that from that point on you are only so
the training the orange curve let's do
it again
so the orange curve is the actual error
you are you are iteratively trying to
minimize okay you're optimizing the
orange curve the blue curve is the
validation loss and it's basically
that's not part of the training you're
not optimizing those values those are
tests so as training move on you do your
stuff in a training set and you check
how well you're doing on other stuff
that you didn't specifically optimized
for and this is used because in machine
learning you actually care about the
other thing okay so sometimes when so
this this thing is now tracked lead
perfect this was even more perfect than
before because basically the
initialization is random so you every
training is different if the blue thing
stays where is it forever
it means that from that point on you are
only basically you're not gaining
anything more because you're very very
doing very good on your training set but
that's not what you're caring about so
if the violation said the binational
loss gets a constant that that's the
best like that value is the best thing
you're going to these are good
indications that there probably no point
in going on with training anymore if
that thing stays constant for a long
time okay so that's just the thing again
okay these are the images from the test
set so these are images the network has
never seen and it's telling me that this
guy is five digits these gases four B's
five it is four so we're happy okay so
for classification we have a nice way to
evaluate performance and various
properties which is discuss if our
measurements function so here you put I
put in the final train laps and this is
basically the test set okay so this is
like measure stuff about my final
training net on these test sets this
returns a classifier measurement object
that you can query for some of the
properties there are a lot let's just be
too dizzy accuracy so this is the
fraction of test examples which are
corrected as if I'd which is 1 so we are
perfect and it is the confusion matrix
plots which tells you let's see actual
class predicted class so this means that
there were six images with four digital
test set and all six have been predicted
as having four digits so of course if
this guy is one it means that there will
be no of diagonal elements here okay
unfortunately we have no three-digit
numbers in the test set and you may
distance suspicious to you you're right
but Sebastian is going to tell about
tell you about that later okay so let's
move on through the most fancy task of
the three which is a segmentation thing
so these so the previous rocket lecture
we were outputting either a single
number or Ln 3 vector but here we want
to do pixel west ossification so for
each pixel we want to to classify
whether it's background pixel or a one
pixel over two peaks or a plus sign
pixel and so on and so on so our output
needs to be an image of the same size of
the starting image so we are we that
shrinking architecture I showed you in
which you shrink the size representation
of course cannot apply here so what is
usually done is that the representation
size is shrunk down and then it's
exampled again to match the input size
and you can see it here input is eating
by 40 and this goes down and then goes
up it goes up again so up sampling is
usually easy to perform using the
convolution layers or just basically
what we call resize layer here what is
it so this thing is basically so the
completion layer is I learned at
sampling so you have a set of a set of
parameters to perform the up sampling
and you learn them this thing has no
parameters other parameters and this is
just basically computing a linear
interpolation of of your input in either
linear or so this is for something
linear you can also have resampling
nearest using nearest neighbor
interpolation so it's it's a fixed
operation so this is the abstraction
step this is some this is just a utility
we don't really care about it's just too
much this is just padding with zeros to
to actually match the output because
after down something every sampling we
didn't get exactly the same size as the
input but that's what we want so we are
too bad ok so this is another commercial
layer so this thing is actually acting
as
fully connected layer is a leaner layer
the difference is that basically what
this layer is doing is that it's
performing the usual fully connected
layer before classification for each
pixel position because that's what we
want and in fact be careful low lamp
after this because you're not actually
using this guy is a convolution you are
using this guy as a linear layer which
which has to slide over each pixel
because that's what you want and as
usual softmax I'm sorry you're right
it's in the in the hidden data set thing
I made you evaluate blindly okay but it
that that's just that's a number that's
12 because you have 10 10 digits plus
sign and background cool okay so let it
struck the relevant part of our training
set and this is the the step in which
I'm going to train on GPU because it's
faster so on CPU this will take you
probably 5 or 6 minutes or 7 minutes
depending on supey you but we don't want
to waste that much time so we are going
to waste 20 seconds
which is better
and again superperfect generalization
look at that boom so again inputs and
masks with the fancy array plots to show
otherwise it will show a matrix which
that's not very exciting
so here oh this I should have mentioned
so actually it's it's even written right
here so I'm show you the class in that
decoder so here we are doing a
classification for each pixel so this is
also some kind of more general class
than a decoder but we have no such thing
yet so what the network will output is
it's a matrix but at each pixel position
you want to have the class but you will
have the softmax probability so the
probability of that pixel belonging to
each class for each pixel okay so what
I'm doing here in fact you can see it
here this guy outputs an 18 by 40 which
is the size of the image times 12 okay
times the number of classes so what I'm
doing here is that I simply I have to do
what the NAT decoder is not doing for me
so it's just I have to pick the class
with max probability for each pixel and
that's what this function is doing so
let's evaluate our segmentation and wow
it's absolutely perfect so if this okay
you may you may you may you may say oh
you're just done you know you're copying
the masks you're not doing anything I'll
show you that if I train for less time
it's actually worse than that
well that's let's let not show a
completely messed up oh it's completely
messed up as well okay so you may see
this is this is the state of the network
after 100 training rounds that's a 300
you get the perfect thing
you like this more the plus is almost
there
you're right okay so now it's Sebastian
turn okay so thanks material so these
these three examples we're gonna try put
them together in a single Network at the
end like we're gonna bow towards that
but there's a little interlude now with
training failures so there's sort of a
common list of things that often go
wrong if you try and train these that
yourself so this is fern Knapp top okay
okay
so the first thing that that often
happens is something called overfitting
you four we heard of us so because this
is like the most probably the most
important thing that goes wrong I'm
going to spend a little bit of time on
this just showing explaining exactly
what overfitting actually is and
visualizing it so the way you see it
often as the one curve goes down very
fast the other one stays up the
validation curve it doesn't track it
that's the symptom so what exactly is it
so you can actually visualize this quite
nicely if you have yet just create some
random data so we're gonna have this is
a sine curve and we've added a bit of
noise to the sine as well we're just
adding a bit of Gaussian noise so the
question is how do we learn yeah how do
we learn to fit this thing so if we have
a network with a lot of layers this is
like a very yeah 300 layers this has
hundreds of thousands of parameters this
network so we can try to Train it and
what happens the loss goes down a lot it
looks like it's going well
and we might as well stop it
and if he plotters okay actually let you
train for a bit longer sorry
okay what okay it's yeah it was doing
something very different previously okay
it is running this in Volterra so let's
try it again
yeah this last very look Smasher
okay I have hope now
okay so what's going on here expand this
okay so we had some data there was a
sine curve and you can see the red curve
here is the sine and for some reason and
this has yeah our data had a bit of
noise and because we had enough capacity
in this network it's strong enough to
actually just fit through the noise
points so it's basically modeling it
just trying to fit these points instead
of working out okay the actual curve
looks more like this so it's fitting the
noise so you don't want yeah you don't
want something like this and what
happens then is that if you sampled from
this distribution wall you know it has
equal probability of the point being
there there so the best guess is exactly
this point over here but because this
network is going off somewhere up here
its predictions are going to be terrible
if you tried it on other data from this
distribution so the first question is
how do you actually know that this is a
this happening so the most obvious way
is that you have a validation set that
is not so data that is not in the test
set and what you often see is this sort
of pattern the training set goes down
and the validation set either goes up in
this case it's just going up and up have
a look at this so it goes down for a bit
and then the validation set sort of
stops and then the the error goes up on
the validation set and we can even you
know you can try calculate what what
this is we can see that on the the
training data the error is very small
but on the test data
the error is quite high so this really
destroys training so how do we M what do
we do about this so I'm going to give
like I think four different solutions
and then give recommendations about what
I think the best way of dealing with
this is so the most simple way is that
you reduce the net capacity so you
reduce the number of parameters
previously the it had lots of parameters
so 300 200 100 and
lots of layers so I could say okay let's
make this a much smaller Network it has
just two layers or three layers it has
yeah
very few parameters and because trainers
okay finished and we can visualize this
now and you can see that this network
now of the black it's very close to what
the actual sine curve was and if you
train this with a validation set you can
see what happens Oh oops those too fast
but you have it over here so the
validation set it just keeps going down
and we can also obviously look at this
and we see that the last on the test set
on the training set is quite well it's
similar to what that the last is on the
on the validation set so the major
downside of the solution is that it's
very hard to tweak the capacity problem
properly like these are you have to
control both the number of layers that
you've got but you also have to control
the number of parameters and how do you
actually tweak this number to get the
exactly the right thing so in practice
no one does this sort of thing so they
don't yeah they don't try and tweak it
too much or the network too much to find
the right network size it's just too
hard so for this you could have explored
a lot of topologies like was a very
simple problem but something that takes
you a few hours to train you're not
gonna be able to do this so the second
one is an interesting solution that is
quite popular so the idea is that we
modify the network and add something
called a drop out layer so what is drop
out oops smack it's difference okay
so drop out layer it's actually very
simple with that sorry
that's fine let's find if I noticed yeah
brackets sorry nom graphics the curly
brackets
say ah so we use this laptop to have a
GPU available it's okay they're good
okay so dropouts it might seem like if
you try to apply this to something it
might seem like it does nothing it just
does nothing so it actually has two
different behaviors so during training
and during evaluation it has very
different behavior so during evaluation
it does nothing it's just the an
audacity but during training and you can
put this over here
it's under what is its net evaluation
mode yes so there's a clever thing okay
you have to write this yeah okay maybe
you shouldn't be my okay you can't yeah
you can interpret it okay okay basically
during training mode what it does is
that it randomly sets out values to zero
and the other ones are scaled by the
probability that you're setting up to
zero so the zero point three mean it's a
probability of zero point three that of
a value gets set to zero so it's
basically just adding noise so this
noise it tries to make it the learning
process more robust so it says okay
we're just going to corrupt inputs and
the network still has to learn what to
do and every time it runs Network every
time it calculates gradients
it just gets randomized so it the one
intuition is that it tries to make it
robust the training so the other way of
seeing it is that it augments the data
so it sees with different activations
even for the same small well if you have
like 10 training examples you know what
when it gets through these
rapidly is the training example looks a
bit different because now it's got zeros
everywhere so this thing if we run it
now so this was the same capacity as the
as original Network 300 units the same
length everything and if we see the
training now hey well we're just gonna
train it for the same time and if you
plotters look at that this thing is much
smoother than the original one
which was this thing here so it's smooth
it out a lot it's made it a lot more
yeah and if we look at the actual
training curve with the validation sets
so it's tracking it very nicely okay
well this is so this actually yeah you
know what happens magic
so it just makes the learning job a lot
harder so then it can't easily as easily
fits that noise that you had in the data
because there's always more noise coming
in so it learns to be robust to noise
put this way there's those
interpretations with model averaging and
things but I won't go to that okay so
this is very simple and sort of standard
probability for dropping out just like
point three like that's a magic number
that a lot of people use and one thing
that you should be very careful of is
that if the network you can see her you
know there's like two hundred units and
if there was one unit over here and you
put a drop out after that you know it
can stop the training completely quite
often so it's a bit dangerous unless you
have you know at least of tens or
something of units that you can drop out
so so there's a suggestion here that
says instead of using a dropout of 0.3
we can have we could have a point five
and then like two point three after that
but right next each other or after I see
you so if you do that if you have too
strong a dropout it basically slows down
the training to like a halt so I'll get
to this now this is actually one of the
major problems with dropouts
okay so dropouts yeah it you can see it
does it has a very nice effect
the major disadvantage is that it slows
down the training because it's
corrupting the data it has to train for
much longer to get to the same learning
as what is what it usually does so it
you pay the price in training time so
the other one that is quite common
although it's fallen out of popularity
of it is ultra regularization
so what this is is an option here you
say method and then whatever method you
want to use the common one is Adam this
is just the training method and there's
something called ultra rigorous asian
and what this does is it it penalizes
the weights being too big so it
basically tries to constrain the weights
it's very similar to saying okay you
know if the weights can be any or the
prior the parameters of the network if
there can be anything there's a lot more
capacity in the network to learn but if
you constrain them to be in a certain
area so in this case you saying okay
we're gonna say we're adding to the loss
the Squared's the total yeah because
we're just going to square all the way
it's a total them and add that to the
lance and that sort of penalizes yeah it
being in a big range so it forces it to
be in a very small range and it reduces
capacity there's also sort of Bayesian
interpretations of those
a nap estimates yeah Adam yeah so this
is the default and we've chosen that by
being you know experiments it's worked
the best and it's also I think it's the
yeah lots of frameworks use that as the
the default right now but maybe yeah if
that changes if there's a better method
that comes out then we'll use that so
just like a small history thing that in
the past's the sort of methods of
optimizing your networks have been quite
flaky and you've had a tweak lots of
values to get a train so this is one of
the major advances that have happened is
that certain optimizes that are
completely robust it is always work ok
so we can now show this well and as you
can see this is much smoother but there
are some problems so if it's not but
what happens if I change this thing to
like that and what do these numbers mean
like that what is the scale of this
number like is this point to the right
thing who knows and you can see this is
not even training it's just flat so this
is very sensitive to this value and
that's why it's not used very often
because it's not clear what what the
right value is you put it slightly too
much and it just stops training it does
nothing so it's a common way of doing
things but yeah it's not popular anymore
drop out is much easier to use because
you can just set okay point three
probability it has a you know it's
something you can use for everything
yeah so you put in as many as you as
improves the generalization error at the
end
is a trial error but in general there's
no hon in terms of the performance so
okay
so the performance if you have a drop
out layer after every single layer after
every linear layer or something the
performance generally would be it will
be better than if you have just a few
but the training becomes very slow so it
says we're it's a sort of toss-up
between you can trade out a bit of speed
but it's taking a few hours I'm gonna
get to the recommendations now so I'm
just going through a little few things
that ideas of what people have tried to
control overfitting and then I'll tell
you what I think is the best sort of
solution okay so the last one the next
one is early stopping so it only
stopping does is that you give it a
validation set and say okay you can
train for whatever time you want but
take the the answer with the best
validation set performance so okay I'm
gonna train this we've got a validation
sets we can see it's decent now it's
going up again on the validation sets up
but net train automatically takes the
one that minimizes the thing on on the
validation set the performance of the
validation set and if I plot this now
it's pretty reasonable it's not
overfitting too much and he said this is
a very plausible fit through these
points so
there are slight downsides for example
if you if you don't calculate the
validation loss fast enough if there's a
chance you know it can over fit quickly
before you see what the performance
wasn't a validation set but that's a
easy thing to control the last one
obviously is that overfitting is
fundamentally a symptom both of a model
that can fit too much but also of having
too little data so if you had infinite
amount of data there's no such thing as
overfitting so on the other hand you
often can't get more data it's an
expensive thing to get if you have more
data you'll be using it ready so one
exception to that is something called
data augmentation and for certain fields
like for images it's an extremely useful
technique so basically you say let's
have an image and let's do it let's say
we're doing a classification job we're
classifying this image as yeah I don't
know a teapot or was not a teapot so one
thing is that you can do any
transformation on this thing that
doesn't change the label so goes up or
reflecting it that's as much of a teapot
is that thing but they're different
pictures so if you use both of them
together
it's a bit more data or more information
to the network than it had before and
you can go on and on with this there's
there's a lot of things you can do so
the most common thing is elect rotations
or crops so you know you could rotate
this picture a little bit slow teapots
you could crop it a bit so like you know
cut it out somewhere there it's taller
teapots so we have a layer actually that
does that does this so it randomly says
again sometimes we're going to half the
time I'm gonna reflect things sometimes
we're going to rotate it a bit and you
can control these settings in illness so
this is a very common technique to
improve overfitting and also improve
generalization because it's seen more
data oh sorry this is just the the
output size so you say yeah
and so it basically if this is an image
of size 300 it'll take a crop of 100 by
100 and then you can also make this
rotation prabhu ze and I think what is
it I forgot about all the parameters on
the documentation okay so my
recommendation for this there's actually
a sort of modern way of doing neural
networks is quite simple so make sure
the first thing most important thing is
that the network is big enough so a big
network is almost always the right thing
to do just make it big so the cost of
bigness is that it takes longer to Train
well sometimes not even that because
it's yeah we'll see now I then take
something like 10% of the data for a
validation set unless you have a truly
tiny data sets you can often afford this
10% it's not ideal but you can probably
spare it and then you can use you put
this in a validation set and you can
actually there's a very simple thing if
you want to automatically take 10% of
your data of your training data for a
validation set then you can use scales
of yeah point one it's just a no so the
default is not to use anything so what
you can also do is if you have a small
data sense oh yeah sorry the neck train
you just train it and toll your you know
your validation performance starts going
up just stop it and it takes the best
value what you can also do is you can
say okay the best value was at this
iteration let me put back my data let me
use the full data set now and only train
up to that that iteration to use to get
a slightly better performance to get
with the extra ten percent but you
always have to use like validation data
it's hard to get away with that with any
other method because you have to somehow
see whether you're getting better and if
you don't keep away keep ten percent to
see that you out of luck but if you
really need that data then you can
always add it back and then just train
up to that iteration number
it was eval idatd that the networkers
yeah it's not overfitting in that regime
but in general you can stop it and then
you have something that's that usually
generalizes very well and big networks
the reason that they don't necessarily
even go slower is that they they get to
optimum performance much faster so after
a few iterations they start overfitting
and you get to the a good generalization
error how quickly okay so the time is
yeah let's go yeah fine
so the next major problem that people
face is the normalization of the data
set so what does this mean so in the
past people have had huge difficulties
training very deep networks so if you
read the literature from the 80s and 90s
deep networks that just didn't train and
people sort of figured out eventually
why they didn't train okay there is some
shaking of heads there are something the
counter examples to this but in general
deep networks had difficulties training
and one of the reasons why they had
difficulties training was that the
initialization procedure was was bad so
what would happen is that you'd
initialize a bunch of these layers and
as the data goes through this it starts
tending towards 0 infinity it blows up
or something and the gradients become
crazy so one of the major advances that
have has made deep learning very easy to
use is that initialization is now a
solve problem and the initialization
actually depends on for example like
what activation use so like ramp has a
different initialization - 10 H so we
automate this whole process we scan your
network and see okay this is the
topology we can find a good
initialization but this initialization
it makes one fundamental assumption it
assumes that your data has mean of 0 and
variance of 1 and the optimizer also
makes an assumption like this so it's
tuned for the same thing it says ok we
assuming that the network has been
initialized
within a certain way and we assuming the
data is coming in looks normalized as
well and then we can choose what the
initial step size will be so the entire
system is tuned to work with with data
that is normalized and if you don't do
that you can get problems so here's a
simple example so just a some nets we
saw this earlier and we're just gonna
instead of using the net encoder for
images we're just going to use raw data
so we're just extracting the data the
image data directly and we're gonna add
let's say a hundred to the image data
pretty simple we get the the training
data and we start training but if you
see this thing here there's lying it's
not I don't know what the validation set
is doing but okay but the other line
it's just flat it's not learning
previously you saw it going down very
nicely and if we modified this if we
didn't add any do anything to this it
will go back to training I think there
we go look at that so you might notice
that the image data is actually not
normalized it's between 0 & 1 so it's
somewhat robust to data that is not
perfectly normalized but the further
away you get from that the greater your
chances of things going wrong so the
recommendation is yen like if you have
problems of convergence the first thing
to try is how yeah what does your data
look like don't just throw anything at
it make its normalize it and things like
classify predicts internally they do
this this is one of the nice things that
using classifier predicts it's that
users don't have to worry about issues
like this one like things just yeah we
automate this process for you but for
the new network framework we don't want
to do
huge pre-processing pipeline because we
you know you might be feeding us data
that is coming we can't look at all the
examples at the same time like there's a
generator syntax floods so it's hard for
us to normalize to look at the global
datasets because it's not necessarily
there we can we support out of core
training so we need some way you know
that uses that it's up to the user to
make sure their data is in the right
form okay I think it's almost finished
I'm gonna miss this one for now and yeah
this is two minutes left so that's not
much okay I guess I'll just mention if
you want to look at this notebook
yourself what what's the last sort of
pieces what you have look to look for
too in your hotel room like this night
so there's a pretty complicated network
that is all these tasks together so it
is if you run this whole thing you get
this lovely thing one network that does
segmentation summing and counting
together and this is one of the cool
things with newer networks is that you
can you can have a single network that
does lots of things at the same time and
it can actually improve the performance
of things of all the separate tasks by
doing them together because you have you
effectively showing it more data and
you've got a processing piece that has
to generalize to many different many
more data points let's put it that way
but yeah so this is what what this last
example is gonna be you have some some
big network that has three different
classes and you can train this thing and
yeah you'll see what happens and yeah
there's also there's some links that
we've got so for example for multitask
learning one problem is like how much
does each loss count fall in the the
learning and there's ways of automating
this like running this thing now we will
not work for segmentation because of
this very reason I take that out because
I want you to show it like happening
live okay fine so what should so your
velocity is one for counting one for
summing up a segmentation I mean in
principle is not clear like what's
optimize in the end some combination of
mister losses but it's not clear what
coefficient you have to put so if you do
nothing the train will just something
for you so saying it's same weight but
here actually you have to with actually
a fairly big coefficient skill and it
should be something like 10 to the 5 so
you have to literally attend to the file
in front of the segmentation loss
actually train properly for all three
tasks so or if I have shown the yeah the
automatic method for this but you can
actually play with these losses and see
what's what happens if you if you don't
treat them and one of the reasons for
this the problem is that if you have
losses like for example the squared loss
you know it if it's wrong it gets very
big like it can be a hundred or
something
well it's things like cross entropy
there have a very different scale like
it's so much smaller loss so if you
weight them the same it says ok the
network I'm gonna focus just on this one
task but you sort of want to have them
be similar weights for each of the tasks
so this is just yeah it's an interesting
world by the Sigma dash will be
completely off
there we go that's something yeah but
you know in order to get a very nice
result you have to put you have to put
something that time to the pipe here
okay
okay cool